tomorrow makes it one year since the
Supreme Court shifted abortion access in
America overturning Roe v Wade and
thereby upending 49 years of precedent
with a predictable result a checkerboard
of new laws around the country Caitlyn
Huey Burns is at the Supreme Court for
us this morning with more on this
unending political fight over access
Caitlyn good morning good morning a lot
of activity on this issue here in
Washington today President Biden will
rally with abortion rights groups and
Republicans including Donald Trump are
coming into town for the faith and
freedom Coalition Conference and this is
all a sign that a year later this is an
issue that continues to be near the top
of the political agenda
[Music]
in America
the fight over abortion access has moved
from the steps of the Supreme Court
[Applause]
to courtrooms and state houses across
the country
many republican-led states have passed
laws rolling back abortion access
including more than a dozen that now
have bans on the books with limited
exceptions while some democratic-led
states have strengthened or codified the
right to abortion it's a critical fight
it's about democracy it's about freedom
and it's proven to be a potent political
issue new CBS polling shows 45 percent
of Democrats are more likely to vote in
2024 based on what's transpired since
Roe was overturned compared to 28
percent of Republicans but a majority of
Democrats say their party has not been
doing enough to protect abortion access
this week in an effort to highlight
where candidates stand on abortion
rights Democrats are rolling out these
Billboards in Times Square and five
other key cities for Republicans after
years of rallying around overturning Roe
unborn children have never had a
stronger defender in the the White House
the issue has become a Flashpoint in the
race for the GOP nomination after
leading the most pro-life Administration
in American history
Donald Trump and others in this race are
retreating candidates are navigating
abortion limits If I Was President
United States I would certainly have a
15-week limit we've enacted the
heartbeat Bill the strongest pro-life
bill in modern Florida history and the
role of the Federal Government this is
an estate's only decision and it's back
in the hands of the people of the states
which is where it should be we should
allow the states to make their decisions
to let them decide what to do and in the
states the CBS News poll finds 53
percent of women said being pregnant in
the U.S is becoming more dangerous and
50 percent said abortion access in the
U.S after roe has become more restricted
than expected women are needing more
services and
and they're looking for places so that
those Services can be provided for them
Sylvia Johnson runs a faith-based
Pregnancy Help Center in Houston Texas a
state with one of the strictest abortion
bans she says the number of pregnant
women looking for help has only grown
for 38 years our practice for the day
that Roe versus way was overturned so
this is when the real work begins
and tomorrow on the anniversary of the
Dom's decision the rallying cries on
both sides are going to continue
anti-abortion activists are expected to
gather around the Lincoln Memorial and
pro-abortion rights groups are expected
to March right here to the Supreme Court
all right got it thank you very much
Caitlin